joining me here my compadre from the NFL
Media Group three times Super Bowl
champion supposed to say that in the
background to happening sorry
good to see you really beginners to see
you rich you're all suited and booted
I am I just got back from radio wrong
and I did a playbook this morning for
NFL okay so I've been a little busy this
so again I I'm assuming I know the
answer this question is that when you
went to radio row the best dress you've
ever been in a food court in your entire
life yes yes it is an amazing food court
here is everything I was eating on her
way here now what you choose over said
it was some type of chicken avocado egg
rolls and I had salmon and salad and I
wasn't able to get it all in so well
you're eating very well I might want to
try to get back that full court is
unbelievable is everything there yes
everything so walking around and sued
anybody think you were security and we
actually had a couple people with me but
it was fun it was crowded okay unique
it's different that that media rose a
little different okay so what do you get
number one what's the question you're
getting asked number one questions oh
it's Brady pissed at Belichick is
Belichick no you seem like because of
all all the the winning that kind of
went away so now something about the
biggest threat all the window for the
last four weeks all the blinds Mariota
and it's still it's important they're
back at the Super Bowl and they said
winning pretty much solves all children
yeah but there's still a meeting at the
end of the seat I'm sure they're not
talking about it right now okay but was
there gonna be like everything is about
this course of course but but is it did
they send out a calendar invite to bella
checks phone
Brady's phone I don't know they all just
real relaxed right he's excited you see
him at the opening night like he was
really really excited he he just seems
like you know it it took so much to get
here he's enjoying the moment but it
also seems and you said he was and you
said the Giants right so that position
has failed and I told you
that or we talk with Pat Sherman well so
now second Hollister theory I want to
know now what's your dish here's my
theory here's my theory that meeting
happens what do you think this is gonna
be great these are like if I wish I had
my hunt through the house Hank take
globe behind you yeah rich is grabbing
the globe that's been without updating
tables you know the hot take globe oh
yeah here we go this is the way it goes
Patriots lose the Super Bowl okay all
right how hot take should I go scorched
on all sorts the earth yeah all right
Brady throws his first his first three
interception game and they lose they
lose bad okay Foles is carried off the
field like Rudy okay which really never
happened right rich of course it's
totally false we wanna and by the way
well I got a USC Trojan here so we've
got brother me at all I'm hot a clubbing
here okay let me spin it a little bit
more for an idea okay so then they all
three of them meet they all three meat
and then Belichick just says I can't do
this anymore
calls up Steve Tisch and they fire patch
they tell him sorry not sorry but I'll
tell you what you lasted longer than
Belichick did with the gym knew you were
going there it's pretty creative on a
spot yeah that's pretty good
what do you think I think I mean I have
you told me to scorch the earth you did
you scorched the entire planet a lot of
other planets but at the time at the
time the Giants job was open and you
even even you thought for a split second
uh I got a new okay I kind of knew that
one I don't know everything but I okay
knew that there would that was never
gonna had I was like that all right so
what's what do you think when Belichick
cuz he did he was actually though in in
top Belichick form did you see when he
was asked this week what's different
about this no he said
what was different about this Super Bowl
trip than the other ones he goes this
one's in Minnesota right I would like to
say I got him to smile this time rich I
sell over 12 times the record last year
was six mm-hmm and I went over I doubled
that answer no okay
plus he had his girlfriend on the side
of the set to hold and I referred to her
in his gear like she dazzled a month
Linda yeah and he really wore his dad's
Fedora that was a special moment for
that's neither every I was wondering why
he had to Hatter he's never worn a hat
like that before
I know his dad's what he said it was
like okay yeah everyone was making fun
of it then he said it's like ooh my bad
sorry Willie McGinest here on the rich
eyes of the show asked Willie McGinest
the one question that if we were given a
chance to check a question in the press
conference this is the one we would
choose the Patriots win Willie that'll
be Bill sixth as a head coach eighth
overall no you're asking Bill Belichick
this question I am Anna yeah and I was
gonna say Bill you know Michael Irvin
has suggested that the trophy be renamed
from Vince Lombardi Trophy to the Bill
Belichick trophy would you be okay with
that
with that movement I'm not on the
committee to make that decision but
because of my greatness and everything
I've done over a couple of decades here
I definitely agree with Michael I said
that today I mean I radio raw media
wrong I've said that like at some point
you kind of take into account all the
different ways to win football games
with all the different personnel groups
and because of the CBA and free agency
and players here and there the culture
change of players I think a lot of
people don't taking account for that how
these players change constantly and how
people like you're the target you're the
number one like nobody-nobody and I sure
a patriot fan wants to see the Patriots
win hmm like it's just it's sickening to
a lot of football fans that they
continue to be consistent and play at a
certain level and get into these games
and if he wins this what I mean it's
only right you change the name of
kofi really yeah I think so huh due to
history I mean I get it but Lombardi and
all that but thinking once I'd won five
NFL championships for the first that's
why I say a championships a little bit
different you know the league was
totally different so then let's talk
about this game Willie McGinest a few
minutes we have left with you sir what
do you think the Eagles can do best
against this Patriots defense because
but we have by the way we had Rodney
Harrison in that chair on Monday and he
echoed the same thing that you said when
they were taking on the Titans right
that it's assignment football do your
job all this Dipsy do RPO stuff they're
gonna be able to handle it if you do
your job rich are all RPO is is a form
of play action and if you read your keys
and you understand and you plan an
assignment football it really doesn't
matter like if I if I have if I'm
playing man-to-man and I have the
running back man-to-man and they plaques
I'm going to them anyway if I have a
receiver in man-to-man
I'm all my receivers and tight ends
anyway it really doesn't matter you know
I think Nick Foles does a great job of
reading but the play is already designed
pretty much in his head it's not really
an option I think he knows what he's
going with the ball you know during the
pass plays the linemen if you watch tape
the live it are moving lateral which
means they're not trying to get off and
get on block so it's not run so then you
know it's it's a pass and it's a form of
play action but if you're just playing
disciplined football assignment it
doesn't really matter like if you're
that side on that side of the ball you
have played a run anyway it's you seen
the Patriots got this no I'm just saying
like they're a smart football team they
understand that and I think Frank Wright
the offensive coordinator for
Philadelphia has done a great job of
changing this game playing around Nick
fall suits or what he does in the last
eight weeks or whatever it is he's been
in his system
so where is New England vulnerable then
well you got to try to attack with the
big play I think I think you got to try
to run the football I mean they've got
some aggressive physical running backs
this team has has thrived all year long
Philadelphia and the play-action game
after having success and running the
football they do give up if there's a
weakness they do give up yards was six
points um I'm not a stats guy but six
points some you know a carry or whatever
but they only gave up six rush
touchdowns the entire season so you'd be
like oh yeah we give up yards but they
don't let people run the ball in the end
zone you know they give up yards from
the 20 to 20 but teams don't score
points you know they don't really get
out to the quarterback but Wow now that
I look at it after we five their average
of 3.2 sacks a game to have more sex
than any team in NFL so they figure out
how to change and make adjustments you
got to be I think for Philadelphia
unlike deal up the last two teams the
Patriots played you have to be able to
be able to make those adjustments and
play better situational football if you
stay the same they'll figure you out in
their car view apart how how much is
your your buddy snoop hurt to see James
Harris walk around your Patriots you
know what right now he immediately went
to social media I wish we had the stuff
here where he where he denounced
distillers and wanted he called for Todd
Haley's head who got well he's finally
got Todd Haley's he's out of there um he
he said he wanted to change his name and
move to a different planet but he also
gave out an invitation to mr. Kraft that
he wanted to perform at the Super Bowl
party so he's still I think that's his
second favorite team outside future he's
performed many times for the Patriots
he's a friend of the organization
hammers a friend of the craft or Elton
John I mean snoop we give Bon Jovi why
not everybody you know you can't leave
with the losers you got to continue to
ride with just I just feel for Pat
Shermer I just feel for him you know
check gets completely roasted for
putting Hoyer in the game and a panic
move in the third who's bringing out the
trophy this year I'm not sure it's not
you right I don't know I think you'll
ever get another chance to go so with
your potty mouth like I did I got
excited it's not it's not like the
largest audience funny about that yeah
there are other there were other
analysts that Fox Alice to that they
went back and had to edit because they
had potty mouth to in the game of
football you put warriors out
brothers all with each other yeah and an
emotional moment like that that's part
of the game you know it's for me I got I
thought I had a uniform on walking it up
to the stage and not forgot looked I saw
the camera I look down Oh Mike I forgot
you're just living in the moment they
got bringing out a trophy with a treat
why was the date you're asking me though
rich can they kiss the trophy well did
they like kiss the blank trophy it's
yours you've earned it now would you
have had to do that it had the Falcons
one two you were doing it win or lose oh
it was uh was it dear Diaw was gonna do
somebody it was the UH oh you know were
you both side when they went up for the
kurta overtime I said if we win the toss
I thought I said prime if we win this
toss mm-hmm cuz it was we in the Atlanta
you know he took oh oh yeah I said you
guys are gonna lose the game I said
there's no chance if we win his toss the
game is over and he was like he's still
going on and I'm sure we want to toss it
just dropped his hair sits over so he
could he knew it too I said if he knew
it he knew it too he knew it too but do
you know Dianna is in Kirsten I think
like 25 years it's really at least not
around I hurt you no no Mike he does not
come I'm still a work in progress you're
you're part of the eight and a half hour
extravaganza correct yes I get to join
you guys miss it it's always fun the
other day today is fun and I you know I
I love the opportunity you're awesome
we have fun you are great and three-time
Super Bowl champion part of our coverage
on NFL Network starting at 9:00 a.m.
Eastern seven o'clock Eastern you're on
NFL Total Access is whether you want to
wear this suit there tonight or do you
change what do you know I'm standing I'm
standing that I didn't bring three suits
for every show yeah that's what that's D
on yeah it's too much going on man I
don't get a chance to sit and rest and
go change and lay it for four hours
before each each show okay they worked
me a little harder William
[Music]
he's the king man everyone else is in
the pit of misery willingness Willie
McGinest on Twitter the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience